I think so many people are keyboard
activists right everybody's good at
sending a tweet about how the world
should be and nobody's doing anything
about it and that just that is just very
much human nature so if you're not
complaining well then I've never I have
no advice for you but I'm pumped
like you did it like you're in control
like you don't complain about it you've
made that choice don't [ __ ] me
I don't want to be exposed by myself
it's it's it's looking at yourself in
the mirror and saying like am I doing
this right so to me there's so many
people there talking [ __ ] about how big
of an entrepreneur they're gonna be and
how much they're gonna achieve and they
don't work on weekends you know I worked
every Saturday of my 20s I plan to
instill kindness into my kids
I plan on instilling perspective into my
kids I plan instilling just being a good
human being I plan on making sure they
don't use their parents wealth and micro
fame and leverage to impose on any other
person I'm petrified of that if my kids
try to Punk their friends on my [ __ ] I'm
gonna beat the [ __ ] out of them like
that just loser DNA you didn't do that
like I just want them to be all in on
them right like I don't need them to be
an entrepreneur I don't need them to
make me proud they don't need to go to
Harvard they don't need to do [ __ ] they
need to be themselves all in and they
need to be kind and I'm good do you feel
like you judge yourself I don't that's a
very very very good observation
and it's what I want for everybody else
we're beating ourselves up like
everybody sucks that's something right
like we all have shortcomings and we all
have strengths and for me it's like why
don't we just audit that like why don't
we just look at it that way and be like
all right well I'm good at this but I'm
not gonna dad like and then and then and
then I only focus what I'm good at right
like I don't dwell that I can't fix [ __ ]
around the house I call somebody to fix
it like I'm not like I'm not a man I
don't give a [ __ ] you're exactly right
man I don't judge myself I'm fully in
love with myself but I'm also fully in
love with everybody else too right it's
not like like it goes both ways
like I tell people to buy in to be
that worked for me it's cuz I buy into
them first like everybody like makes
these big deals out of things that just
don't matter its perspective you know my
selfishness comes from my selflessness
like it's what makes me feel good I say
to my mother my mom is the epicenter to
every single person her life to me
everything's about breathing right like
to me everything is about like take full
ownership for everything and then
everything gets easy because then you're
in control and then learn how to love to
lose like for me my games simple right
it's all my fault so now I'm not mad at
Lindsay or D rocker that's it my fault
I'm empowering them so it's actually
true my fault
now oh we lost this or this didn't
deliver or we [ __ ] up alright so yeah
all on me
you know I enjoy losses now all of a
sudden like what you become completely
invincible I feel invincible I really
genuinely outside of the health of
myself and 20 people feel 100%
invincible as a person I know what my
intent is I want to do good at nobody
else's expense I'm far from perfect we
all are and so just easy it feels very
light to live life I'm just in a good
mood like I like it's like you know I've
been like trying to forget I'm like why
is this thing even exist it's actually
the most common-sense thing of all time
wise karma seem weird the [ __ ] is karma
like wait a minute so you're telling me
like if you do lots of good things that
weirdly good things happen to you yeah
that seems like common sense I always
say if you want to be an anomaly you
have to act like one like people want
all these special things to happen but
then they're acting like everybody else
I want to do the following I'm
fascinated by the same thing that
attracts so many millions of people to
people that are selling [ __ ] those
same people are attracted to me
and what I want to do is suffocate out
all those other people and become the
Alpha of that entire world of people
that are hoping and are desperate to
look at me and what I want to do is
inspire two 14 year old girls in Kansas
City right now to build a billion dollar
company on having a bunch of employees
hugging each other in the halls
I want my pedestal moment I want to
become that big and what I want to come
from that is that kids that aren't even
born today think that they can build a
five billion dollar company and be a
great guy or great gal I want to build
the biggest building in town ever by
just building the biggest building in
town while I think most people try to
tear down everybody else's building so I
think positivity and good is practical
advice to building an empire and I want
to be the poster child of the person
that built the biggest baddest empire
and did it by being a good dude along
the way I want to do it and I want to be
a rockstar right like and that's where
you influence people like you know like
I want to do it
but I also want to be the most popular
and so then that person's like oh I want
to be him so I guess I'll be nice like I
want to literally take people who have
DNA that's kind of nice and make them
more nice because they think that's how
I became big
so I basically want to trick the
business world into becoming kinder
[Music]